i zoomed with this gentleman and his
colleague from the knuckleheads podcast
when it was
coming out um quentin richardson and
this man
give you some great insight to the nba
and life in general
on their knuckleheads podcast where all
podcasts can get acquired darius miles
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you darius
okay how you doing better for talking to
you what do you think of this playing
tournament
what do you think of it oh i think it's
exciting uh
if i was playing in i probably wouldn't
want to play the extra game
but uh yeah i think it's exciting i
think we're going to see a lot of 50
point games 40 point games a lot of
we're going to see teams come from that
10 spot and get on in and knock somebody
out there 8-7
well i mean i don't know if we're going
to see that this year um
you know uh and that's that that may be
well look
it's definitely something that i i know
that players are perhaps as you pointed
out not too happy about playing in
um and i imagine one of those tonight
would be steph curry i mean uh
he's in an elimination game tonight as
opposed to already being in the
tournament i'd be very nervous if i'm
uh uh an entity that would love to see
steph curry in
warriors right yeah they definitely got
to be cautious you know they got to play
their best game now
you know because if they don't you know
washington just blew out
you know the pacers i know the patients
didn't want to come in and play like
that so
now with steph curry you know it's
definitely butterflies but you know
he do what he do and that is something
else
according to uh you know all of our
eyesight
it was really something what we saw the
other night so
darius who who who do you think uh i
guess utah will be flying the uh
the uh memphis grizzly flag tonight they
don't want any piece of what the
warriors might might give us
how dangerous do you think the lakers
are gonna be now that they've gotten
through into the uh
into the turn the big tournament darius
uh
i think they definitely gonna be
dangerous but i think phoenix is with
chris paul and
and uh i mean uh brooks i think they
definitely gonna test they might
well how um how do you see it playing
out
i think they're gonna go about six at
least six seven games
i think it's gonna be uh it's not gonna
be a pushover i think phoenix then
revamp the organization
and they ain't come to play and i know
they come to play with definitely chris
paul leading them
and um what did you make of lebron
saying he doesn't think he'll ever be a
hundred percent again
with this i think that's true you know
you know we all believe we are superhero
until you know the injuries start
getting on us and
you start slowing down a little bit i
think he's just speaking the truth
did you ever sense something like that
happening with you
in your in your career darren yeah you
definitely
yeah you definitely do i get to that got
to that point with my knees that i had
that first surgery and uh
i never felt like i was jumping the same
you know
you feel invisible when you can do all
your things that you you work
so hard to create in your body but
you know after injuries and you know 82
games every year
you know you start to slow down a little
bit do you think uh let's talk about
your former team
uh in the clippers darius uh i'm with
darius miles here
on the rich eyes and show third overall
selection of the
2000 nba draft back in the day right
here on the rich eisen show
so um what uh what did you did
do you think the clippers were were
tanking the last weekend of the season
to avoid the lakers do you think that
was happening
i think that's just part of the game i
don't think they were really tanking
i think they were just preparing their
guys to to get ready for this tournament
you always want to put yourself in the
best position
possible and you know evidently it
wasn't about
where they was there or trying to get
higher it was about them getting their
guys healthy and getting together
so they can't the concern
uh that we're hearing do you pay it no
mind no credence that
it sends a message to the locker room
that you know uh we want to avoid a
certain team because we might have a
problem with that team as opposed to we
can beat any team that's in front of us
no i think they got i think that
championship they got championship
pedigree all over the team now with
kawhi
and serge and ty ryan lew i think that's
definitely not the case
i think they're ready to go and you know
they're gonna try to give they put their
best foot forward especially
with what happened in the bubble last
year so who's the best team in the west
blake you didn't stutter
yeah lebron james anthony davis is
you know they're defending champs you
gotta respect that so
you think there's the the the most
dangerous seventh seed maybe in the
history of seven seeds
that's what you've ever seen ever it'll
never probably be this again
and that would probably be this again
well i mean there's
which team do you think could give them
the hardest time then
uh the signs and the clippers
so you think it's lakers like the sun
like the sun's with chris paul right the
way he controlled the game and he's
he controlled the pace of the game and i
feel like with the clippers
because uh with kawhi pg they got the
makeup
to withstand them what about the east
who do you think is coming out of the
east jerry smiles uh
i think brooklyn but i think uh
milwaukee definitely got a good chance
why don't you mention philadelphia uh
i just feel like they're just not over
the edge they ain't got it though yet
why is that uh
they they look good but i just feel like
giannis and brooklyn
look better okay uh
when it all comes down to it who's your
mvp of the season
darius miles give me your mvp steph
curry
why is that this is uh he went on a run
like he went on a run unstoppable run he
looks like the mvp right now
okay but if you look at the game these
last couple of months
steph curry probably beat everybody's
choice i mean 33 years old as well
doing this this year and having the
scoring title it's unbelievable who's
the best scorer
i got darius miles a few minutes left
with darius miles here on the rich
eisenshire was the best scorer
you ever saw in in person or played
against or played with
i'll give you michael jordan give me a
good one give me a good story about that
you gotta go um just uh when i first met
him uh
everybody was kind of scared to kind of
guard him we used to pick up and santa
barbara was scared to guard him and when
uh
i just accepted the challenge i was a
sophomore in high school
long lengthy and you know i accepted the
challenge and i blocked this shot
like the first kind of two times i
tipped it then i blocked it
and then i didn't block it or tip it no
mo and he scored everything else
okay now let's let's let's walk me
through this how how did you get
involved
in this is the pickup game in santa
monica yeah santa barbara here
camp and he invites uh three high school
kids and a bunch of college kids out to
the camp to be counselors
for the kids and uh he invited me omar
cook
and uh somebody else and uh after the
kids you know do their thing all day we
play in pickups and mike play pickups
with the college kids and there'll be a
few nba players come
down and this was my first year ever
doing it that's why i did it every year
after that
but uh my first year ever doing it and
you know i got on the court first
and and you know like everybody was
matching up and then nobody walked over
there with mike
so i walked over there and i was the
youngest guy there
and uh i think that's why he respected
me that's why he uh
put me on his brand i think that's why
we got the relationship to this day no
kidding because you
you were not shying away from the
challenge
okay so what did he did he say anything
to you or did you dare say anything to
him after you
tipped one of his shots and then blocked
another one oh he said everything to me
i can't really repeat it
he said everything to me but you know
because i blocked this shot and i tipped
like a
i don't know if he was shooting or
passing in her after the fade away
because i was kind of all up on it
and then the next one he pumped fake
blow me in the ribs fade away
boom off the backboard uh the one hand
fake
up jumping uh he just got to going to
work
and it wasn't nothing i could do normal
so
he elbowed you first i like that he he
gave you one of the chops first yeah he
made me respect my ribs
putting my hands up and getting that
close-up on him
so you know if you're respecting your
ribs you can't you ain't gonna put your
hands up too many times
and you don't know i was long i was six
nine right
seven foot wingspan so he was creating
space
you know and that's what he did and you
think this whole
exchange and you showing yourself
in this exchange is what led to him
signing you to his brand
shortly yeah i feel like the reason i
have the relationship with mike and uh
i was assigned to his brand and i was
there every year and being in his
presence was because uh
he accepted he respected me accepting
the challenge from him
darius gary smiles here on the rich
eisen show
when you have you you and q having kwame
brown on from the front seat of his car
when are we having that
uh on the knuckleheads podcast darius
well called around the brother
you know that's why i straight out of
high school brother i know that you go
he
he was in the draft right after you so
um yeah he made history
well he's still it seems like right now
but he's
he's he's really far he's firing on all
cylinders right now
darius what do you think of what he's
what do you think you got any thoughts
on the subject matter
no i really got no thoughts on it you
know uh wish all them bros the best and
you know how he enjoys a good
i'm loving it you know it's like a kid
in a candy store you know you get the
grapes and man you just
you can tell them how how much you think
they great well who you who have you had
on and who do you want to have on that
you haven't had on yet well i want to
have michael jordan on
of course well is that him calling you
right now would that be
no i want to have michael jordan on the
course but um
we'd have some greats on uh this season
coming up we don't have
you know like dr jay got a few special
guests few uh
loch ness monsters that people ain't
heard from in a minute so
i'm excited for this new season i like
that loch ness monsters they have not
heard from
in a minute and then they'll show
themselves on the knuckleheads podcast
it's basically what you're saying i like
that okay
uh last one for you if that was michael
jordan calling in the middle of this
interview would you have answered that
in the middle of this live
radio and tv interview anyway darius
no questions as of course you know what
um
uh that's michael on our other line
right now so no i mean
i don't no it's not
but i don't blame you i i wouldn't uh i
would not i would not blame you
so uh when it all comes down to it um
and we'll have you on as the
playoffs move along uh your your
prediction right now
nets lakers or someone's gonna crash
this party
uh ned clippers you know i'm still a
clipper so you know i gotta root for my
guy
that would be something else i mean it
really would
that would be something else certainly
if you know kawhi and pg
and kd and hardin and kyrie
steve nash i mean that would and then of
course blake griffin
standing in the way of the clippers and
vice versa
that's right and deandre jordan all
right darius that's uh that's some food
for thought thanks for it um appreciate
the time and
uh you know let's uh let's let's keep uh
connecting
appreciate it all right thank you right
back at you that's darius miles right
here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here